?
MOREER, HOW CERUST T
THENSRSEAN'T ANDR OUR
OUN'T.JOINGE NOWS MEOMPE
X NS CORITORND FORR
.
. SEETAR THESELYMPICS
AREOISETOE A MSIVE P.R
WE'R -- FHE PREDENT A
YE WE' PWINGIG AWA>>OODVENI, LA.
ADO BEITH Y.I' BEE ASKG FOR OUR
HLETES N TO G T BEIJING
R A WHI NOW
IEGRETHAT THE LEARSHIIN
E UNEDTATE AND THE I.C.
FAILEDHE OMPIC
IAW CL LISUN.
WE WE SITNG ON HH-UPEATS
IN T L.A COLEU.
IOV THI EVE.
PRESIDEN.OUP T
THISILLE KNOWN AS THEGECIDELYMPS
AT'S TAK PLA I WTERN
CHIN ISOTHING SHORT OF
GENOCI.
E VIRUS CAMFROMHE WUHAN
ALMOERTALY TS VIR WASHOTEDROUN .
SECO, N ONLYRE WE OPNG
ONEFHEREEST HAN
RIGHIOLANG LEADE INLL
PUTTINGUR ALETENS AERY
FFULTLACE
AGIN O OF THEWANTTO SAY
BEIJING  THEOSTURILEDCI INHE WOS
EIRELL ONES ORPADSR
THEY'REAYINO SOMNELSE,
YOUAN BETHEHISE
COMMUNT PTY WL BE AEO
TRAC EVETHING TY DO,VERY
PLAC THEO AND EVETHIN
TH SAY
EYL RORDT.
IT'L BESED FOR CHINE
MMISTARTYURPOS FOR
TI OOING>>auraUST DAYAG, TH
LITEOTIC SRY ITHE
ASHITON POS"T REVLED
CHINA W MINING R SIAL
DIA DA O WESRNER POST
VI OF BDING DOCENTS AND
NTCTS RE OF 300 CHISE
OJF
INCLUS OERS R
FTWA DESIGNSO CLECT DAT
ONORGNARGETS FM SOCES
SUCHS TTT,ACEBK AND
HERESTE SIAL MEDIA
I GSS I IN TROLE,
MR. CRETY.
K M I I CARE.
NO OASOVEREDSXCEP
TH ONEIECEHAFULLINHE
"WASHITON ST"."
>> Y KNO I HN'T ENHE
CERTNLY KNO PRESELYHAIT
IS THEREALNG ABO.
S TYOURHOW --OODNS IT
MIT HAVE BN MO THAAEAR
TH RESOOMIKTOK.D ABOU
TH FAC THE CNESE WERE
SURVLLIN EVERY DA SND
RVEIINGID HERINHE
ITEDTATE USING TTOTHE I NO SHHIA
PRIVE EITYO SUC TNGS
IVATINFOATION.
PURPES OF TIR GERNMT.YHE CHISEOT
WEE SN THE PSO THA
DOEST CEBOUT BASIC DNITY
REPORTER IN JAIIN HONG NG.
PEOP ACRS T WLD THI ALL
PARTY.M THEHINE COMMUNI
FOR EACHF T THISNDUNTAB
SHOULDT B PMITT TO
OLPICOVEMT.E GLO OFHE
Lau: THE FAC WEVER
TNIQU ACCSNTO THA
HAN LABWE WE NEVERBLEO
EXAME T ORINAL DOCENTS,
THENFORTI O WHOATIE
ZE WAS.
YEAR ECTLYATER OH, IS
HE'L BE STINGHEREN ALLF
S SPLENR INHE SDIUM
BRAGNG TY WEREBLEO
INTOHEIRPARTNTS ANDE'RE,
NOT SDI DIPMATS TUGH
THER MR. SRETA.
AT'L SHOW 'E
ES TT ME A DIFRENCE IN
END WE' NOT SENDING
PLOMATSHERE>> NOT AIT.
DSN'TAR
HE'LLET THANC TO STA ON
E RLDTAGE
L BE CARRIED ONMERICAN
GLAL MIA OTHE OPENG A
NIGHTF T GAM A THERE
ACRO T WOR TKING ABOUSG CHISE PS
E GREATEMOCCYF CHI AND
AT AONDEUL NION  IS.TH IS A DACE
SHOWS YOU THE I.O.C.TSEL
ISNNECD OM T CENAL
INGSHAT MATR.
Lra:R. SRETARY,
U'VE BEE